pour cette troisième édition on tient un
bilan très positif de l'été à jouer 2019
déjà sur la participation une
participation qui en hausse cette année
de soco international
on a des étudiants qui viennent donc du
canada le sénégal de la côte d'ivoire
on a des projets qui ont été très
intéressants malgré des chemins qui ont
été assez en dents de scie pendant ces
trois jours de création pendant les
trois jours d'immersion qui a eu avant
donc les ts b
ils ont pu découvrir toute la martinique
ont rencontré des professionnels du
terrain voir les différentes
problématiques donc présenté par ces
professionnels des problématiques aussi
auquel ils ont fait face comme le
transport avec des bouchons pour partir
et revenir chaque soir à l'hôtel et vous
les partenaires aussi c'est une très
belle édition puisque on a réussi à
exporter donc mais tsv dans différentes
nationalités dans différents pays et
aussi dans différentes écoles aucune
visibilité qui sort en dehors de la
martinique et les grands gagnants de
cette idée sb 2019 sur les étudiants
martiniquais puisqu'on a réussi à
ramener en martinique des étudiants des
problématiques mais aussi une expérience
qui est quasiment unique dans la caraïbe
prochaine édition la quatrième on
prépare la quatrième édition mais on
prépare aussi une évolution parce que on
se dit que en trois ans on a déjà
commencé à faire un tour du sujet donc
la quatrième édition doit être novatrice
et en compte de nouveaux sur les
partenaires vont nous accompagner nous
permettre d'aller encore plus loin